the iPhone tennis max has just had its
six-month anniversary and we're gonna go
in-depth with which features and changes
made our experience with it really
special as well as some of the features
that turned out to be gimmicks compared
to the iPhone 10 the regular tennis
isn't really much different and to be
honest it's not worth the upgrade now
the tennis max is where things get
pretty interesting the six and a half
inch display is truly incredible it
makes a UI wider in it's so immersive
compared to the smaller size the notch
did say the exact same size but since
the screen is much larger it seems so
much smaller now and it's not as
distracting anymore
the display itself is pretty awesome it
one display mates best display of the
Year award
but the galaxy s 10 is coming in the
display is probably better I'll be doing
a comparison as soon as we get our hands
on the S 10 tomorrow so make sure to sub
see don't miss out on that after 6
months of using the iPhone 10 s max
without a case it's now got a bunch of
micro scratches on the stainless steel
band especially on the top but you can
easily polish them out I recommend using
a tempered glass screen protector
since max's iphone got a couple of
scratches on it within the first couple
of days i've had mine on since i bought
it and it hasn't chipped or cracked once
i'll leave a link to it in the
description below it's only been six
months since i switched from an iphone 8
plus and i'm already used to all of the
gestures my absolute favorite is swiping
left and right on the home bar to switch
between apps it's so much quicker than
using touch ID i still use cable
charging more than wireless since the
battery life is so great that i simply
plug it into the wall every night before
bed the difference in battery life
coming from the iphone 10 is massive the
iphone tennis max seems to last forever
and anyone hungry for extra battery life
to just buy the max instead of buying
one of those silly battery packs backs
and wireless charging it's great if you
work in an office setting just place
your iphone on a wireless charging stand
and you'll be going home from work every
day with a completely full battery the
most annoying thing about the 10's is
that you still get a slow 5 watt charger
in the box it doesn't really matter for
overnight charging but if you're trying
to get some quick juice it sucks to have
to buy additional accessories for fast
charging I'm fairly confident that the
2019 iPhones will come with apples 18
watt USB C power adapter so I'm really
excited for that the speakers are simply
incredible much
than the ones in my old eight-plus and
the stereo separation is so much better
than on other Android phones face ID is
awesome and it works so reliably now
that I don't miss touch ID one bit I
have a friend who refused to upgrade
because of the lack of touch ID and when
he eventually did he got used to it
almost instantly and now he's really
happy with it
he only mentioned a couple of downsides
where a face ID won't work when it's
laying flat on a table and it has issues
when you're laying down the new iPad pro
has faced ID and it works in any
orientation so hopefully the next iPhone
will be getting this as well after a
week or two with this phone I basically
never used an emoji again it's honestly
a gimmick so don't count that in your
decision-making process it's been over a
year since the iPhone 10 was released
and they are now tons of apps that use
face ID for logging in and I've got to
say that it's so convenient that it
changes the way you'll use your phone
forever onto the cameras portrait
selfies are amazing they make selfies
look countless times better however I
basically never use any of the portrait
lighting filters they honestly don't
turn out that well what I really enjoy
is the new adjustable book of feature
this is an absolute game changer and I
use this all the time this feature alone
helps the 10s be a significant step up
from the iPhone 10 now that rear cameras
are insane the dynamic range is
incredible in the quality looks amazing
I bought my wife an iPhone 10s and she's
been taking awesome looking photos for
her business with a little bit of
editing they can look somewhat like
professional DSLR photos so it's a great
investment for any business however
there is a problem with it and that's
the whole beauty gate dilemma photos
just look a bit flat and they lack
contrast unfortunately it's also the
main reason why the dynamic range is so
good so you can't really have the best
of both worlds without editing each
photo now let's talk about performance
the new seven nanometer 8-12 processor
gives us a decent boost and processor
performance over the 10 in a massive
boost in graphics performance this makes
playing demanding games like fortnight
incredibly detailed and smooth even at
60 frames per second however in basic
day-to-day tasks I honestly didn't
notice much of a difference coming from
my iPhone 8 plus both phones are already
so powerful that the UI is perfectly
smooth on either phone we finally
reached the
where we're no longer limited by
hardware and any extra performance is
used for shooting better quality video
at higher frame rates and basically just
flexing realistically the best part
about the iPhone 10s max is a size to be
completely honest if there was only the
smaller iPhone 10s this year I wouldn't
have upgraded the size is really what
makes this phone worth it if you still
haven't upgraded and you're thinking of
doing so here's my advice if you already
have an iPhone 10 don't upgrade to the
iPhone 10s you won't feel much of a
difference apart from the camera
features and you'll ultimately be
disappointed instead go for the iPhone
10s Max and you'll easily feel where
your cash went the iPhone 10 R is also a
great option for the budget minded but
the display sucks and it's really thick
compared to the iPhone 10s now if you're
still using an iPhone with touch ID then
the smaller iPhone 10s will be a great
upgrade for you and if you've used and
enjoyed plus models of iPhones then I
recommend going with the tennis max and
finally if your current iPhone works
fine then I would honestly wait it out
and see what Apple's got in store for us
with their 2019 iPhones this has been
with you with max tech thanks for
watching and if you enjoyed this video
make sure to hit that sub button before
you leave
[Music]